for all that you love it's called enormous
this is truly delightful oh yeah
I'm coming for you all
right guys we got work to do
thank you
so do you hang out in the hood
all the time or do you just come
up here for our food and women where's our waiter
you and I tell each other everything right always
okay this is my case I've got to make
this right your reputation is proceed
you there you go thank you that's nice to
hear not in a positive way I'm afraid oh not
okay okay and whatever I need to be to keep
her safe how do you feel coming out of retina
we have no idea what they're capable
of but life is full of surprises
[Music]
something is happening and I don't trust them
for all that you love it's called enormous
[Applause]
that was serious
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Zack Snyder
and Netflix just released a short Rebel Moon
trailer as part of a larger Netflix trailer
for their upcoming 2023 stuff like here's all
the movies that we're releasing in 2023 that's
why they didn't have live action avatar The Last
Airbender footage and they're still hoping to see
some footage for that at some point Rebel moon is
Zack Snyder's new movie that he's been working
on for a while that actually started Life as
a Star Wars movie that he was planning on doing
for lucasfilm a long time ago so we'll break it
all down because there's some cool Easter eggs
in the way this movie got started if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing a giveaway for IMAX tickets for
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania because that's
getting ready to come out all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just post all your
Rebel Moon theories in the comments Below based
on the trailer footage as you would expect it
looks like it's going to be super crazy in a
good way the movie's about a peaceful Colony on
the edge of the Galaxy that's threatened by the
armies of a tyrannical Regent named belisarius
The Desperate civilians dispatch a young woman
who has mysterious past to seek out Warriors
from new nearby planets to help them challenge
the region it stars Charlie Hunnam hansu Anthony
Hopkins and Sophia boutella that you see in the
trailer the young woman in the synopsis is
Sofia Patel's character I know I mentioned
the live-action avatar The Last Airbender series
that Netflix is working on but Sophia batela's
character is actually named Cora but it's with one
R I don't think that's inspired by avatar The Last
Airbender or Legend of core or anything like that
I think that's just a coincidence Charlie Hunnam
and Diamond hansu seem like they're the Warriors
that she seeks out on nearby planets to help their
colony here the large ship Landing seems like it
belongs to the evil region character that might
be Anthony Hopkins character but I didn't spot
him anywhere in the trailer footage so we'll see
who he winds up playing in the film if it wasn't
clear when he's talking about it it's actually
a two-part movie like this is just part one of
Rebel Moon part two will be a completely separate
film that he's working on later so I'm assuming
there'll be some kind of cliffhanger at the end
of the first movie This is actually Zack Snyder
talking about the film with Michael giacchino
who just got done directing werewolf by night for
Marvel yeah you know the movie's about like um uh
planet um kind of not in our you know it's it's
a space fantasy so it's kind of not there's no
Earth necessarily there's a community on a planet
a farming planet and um these uh there's a bunch
of bad guys um the mother world's armies are in
the area and they need to be fed so they they
come to the village and ask for uh the village to
feed them basically while they're doing their War
yeah in that area of the Galaxy and of course
um they are not uh kind about asking and the
result will probably be the obliteration for the
village and so the villagers decide to fight and
so you know they have to go out into the Galaxy
and collect some soldiers to four years to help
them but as he talks about he says that he hopes
this Rebel moon will turn into its own special
thing like its own franchise and do more films
after it he does talk a little bit about his
Star Wars influences there but he's talked about
this in the past as well originally what happened
is about 10 years ago before Disney bought Star
Wars and before he had finished releasing the
first man of steel Superman movie Disney had
started taking pitches for what would become
the Star Wars sequel Trilogy like Star Wars the
Force awakens and he like many other directors at
the time pitched his take to lucasfilm so for a
brief hot second there was a chance that he was
going to make the snyderverse version of the Star
Wars sequel movies he said his pitch was rejected
at the time but this was back in 2012 when they
said no to his ideas and he says out of that he
took his original Star Wars pitch and took out
the trademark Star Wars stuff the locations of
the characters like Luke Skywalker the like and
essentially just reimagined everything is the
exact same type of movie same scenario that looked
and moved the same way same basic story in general
just know Star Wars copyrighted stuff maybe with
a Wilhelm screen but that's not copyrighted like
no studio owns The Wilhelm scream and named it
Rebel moon like Rebel as in Rebels from Star Wars
but imagined it as an Endor type of movie like
he mentions during his interview he hasn't fully
revealed exactly what would have happened in his
Star Wars movies but he said it was meant to be
a darker grittier Kurosawa Seven Samurai type
of film on a planet-like Endor which is where
all the Star Wars comes in obviously George Lucas
has said for a long time that the original Star
Wars movies were heavily inspired by Kurosawa
Samurai films like Hidden Fortress so it makes
sense that Zack Snyder would pitch something based
on similar things and after they turned him down
and he took the name Rebel moon in the scenario a
lot of the characters and just took the Star Wars
out when you look at the trailer footage here and
you listen to the synopsis for the movie it does
feel like a very Seven Samurai Kurosawa type
of movie a bunch of badasses get together to
protect a village from a really powerful force
when he says a dark and grittier take on Star
Wars a good example would be his DC movies like
Batman v Superman the Justice League Snyder cut
movies that go way harder just in general than you
would expect in the very specific hyper stylized
look that Zack Snyder gives to all of his movies
but done in Space Opera style I don't know how
things would have turned out if he had wound up
making the Star Wars sequel movies it sounds like
he would have had to lead the DC movies early on
if that had happened because if he was pitching a
Star Wars Trilogy in 2012 before Man of Steel was
out it sounds like at that time his contract to
come back for Batman v Superman and Justice League
hadn't been finalized yet or Warner Brothers was
just waiting out Man of Steel to see how it would
perform financially in theaters before they hired
him back at the time that was all happening you
remember the Slate of DC movies that they had
planned was completely different that changed a
couple times over the years when they hired him
to come back after a Man of Steel it was for
Batman v Superman with the idea that they had
already planned on doing his his Justice League
Trilogy like by the time they hired him to come
back for Batman being Superman they're like okay
we're gonna let you do Justice League now and
that's why they let him do Man of Steel too as uh
Batman v Superman movie instead of just a straight
up Man of Steel 2 sequel like they would do with
most directors because they were trying to get
their Justice League movie out within a couple
years of that and they wanted to get all the
characters together way faster it wasn't until
Batman v Superman was released in theaters in
2015 that Warner Brothers started messing with the
Justice League Trilogy of movies when Batman the
Superman came out in theaters they were already
deep in production on the first Justice League
movie and critical response was so polarized into
that to Batman v Superman that Warner Brothers
freaked they canceled Justice League three like
they told them that he could only do two Justice
League movies so they had to get all of his story
out in two movies now and a little while after
that they did it again they freaked again and
said he could only do one Justice League movie
and then tragedy struck his daughter died and
we saw what happened next Joss Whedon came on it
turned into a huge debacle for several years cut
to recently he came back to do his original plan
and for the Justice League Snyder cup with a few
minor tweaks and additions because he didn't know
if he'd ever get to come back for more and that's
how we got the Justice League Snyder cut he did
reveal what his full plans were originally for
Justice League sequels two and three I've done
a much larger video for it because there's so much
stuff in there like they would have been huge I'll
post a link for that video in the description
below because it gets just as crazy as you would
expect it to they actually asked him Point Blank
if he's coming back to do more DC movies like have
they contacted you to come back and do more after
the Justice League Snyder cut as he says he has
not been subsequently contacted by any of the
new people at Warner Brothers in DC about the
Snyder versus movies or doing more DC films and
I don't think that he's lying about that like I
think he's trying to basically say no they haven't
said anything to me yet and you have to remember
that I think this interview was happening before
James Gunn was hired by DC so at the time Henry
Cavill still thought that he was coming back as
Superman for more Man of Steel movies Gal Gadot
was still making Wonder Woman 3 they were still
planning on building up to a new movie version of
crisis on infinite Earth a much bigger version
of the one that we saw in the DC TV series but
then James Gunn was hired like a month after that
and elected to reboot pretty much everything not
every single thing like not 100 but like 99 of
it he did say before the end of January he would
reveal the full DC Phase One of movies and we
know that there's going to be a brand new Superman
movie during that because he revealed that he's
actually been writing a new Superman movie with
the younger Superman but recently people saw him
reading All-Star Superman and that is probably one
of the better Superman stories so a lot of people
are like wait a minute does that mean that the new
Superman movie is inspired by All-Star Superman
it sounds like it'll be an original story like
it won't be a direct comic adaptation but I will
do videos for all the big announcements that he
winds up making that should happen pretty soon
so make sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss those videos we'll get more Rebel
Moon trailers later this year because the movie's
not coming out to the end of the year they're
probably going to wait till this summer before
they release like a really big trailer the Super
Bowl is coming up there's always a bunch of big
trailers from everyone during that of course I'll
do a bunch of trailer videos I don't know what
Netflix has planned for that at but there'll be a
bunch of big Marvel trailers there'll be a big DC
trailer for The Flash movie everyone click here
for my brand new Ant-Man in the Wasp Quantumania
trailer video in Easter eggs and click here
for my new Mandalorian season 3 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!